- Wait.
I look icky.
Okay.
Okay, I think I'm ready.
- [Interviewer] All right,
Jobena, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Jobena] Chicago, Illinois,
Louis Hospital, Cook County.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your childhood.
You live with your parents as a kid?
- Yeah.
Well, they were there, but
not really there because,
in Chicago, okay, okay, my daddy
was the coldest pimp
you ever wanted to know.
I mean, he had hos and shit.
I'm his first, I'm his first baby
and I grew up, at that time
I could never want for anything.
If I thought I wanted
something, I already had it.
My mom was his main bitch
if you wanna call it that,
you know what I mean?
And if she yelled at me
and did anything to me,
he would beat her.
I seen him put her face through,
through my color TV one time,
'cause she yelled at me.
Threw her downstairs.
They used to do the heroin shit.
I seen so much shit in my life.
And then my brother, me and brother
are the only one out of
all my mama's children,
got the same mama and the same daddy.
And I was called baby girl, you know,
me being the daddy's girl.
We didn't really want for anything.
We lived in a condemned
building in Chicago, right?
We stayed on West Post Street.
It snowed really hard.
I remember, basically I
was like two years old
when my other little brother after...
Okay, so it's my sister,
my older sister, then me,
then my brother, then my
other little baby brother,
little Wawa, he died in my mama's arms
because they were high off
that fuckin' heroin shit
and you know how the
babies squirm and shit
in the blanket or whatever.
I remember, it's like,
I don't too much wanna
remember stuff like that.
I try and it don't stop.
People do the type of shit
that go through my mind.
They wouldn't wanna be around me.
I don't even wanna be around me sometimes,
but everywhere I go, there I am.
I feel lonely, lost and scared.
I'm all by myself.
I don't have nobody, my mama dead now.
My granny dead now.
I wanna help people, but I can't.
I don't know how and I try to help.
Not everybody wanna get help.
I don't know, I don't know,
I been through, mm-mm.
There's, okay, okay, listen.
Can I just go ahead and tell you the help?
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood.
- Okay, okay, okay.
'Cause I'm like spitting,
I'm bouncing around
because when I was little, I was told shut
the fuck up, get outta here,
you ain't got no business even...
That's why I talk so fast, 'cause I try
to hurry up and get it out because
I was always told to shut the fuck up.
And I wanna be heard.
I want somebody to listen to me
and hear me.
It's the difference
between mentally hearing,
get outta here, no kids in here.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood.
- I'm telling you.
This is what they were telling you.
Listen, in Chicago, you know
they got the skeleton keyholes, right.
Adults in there doing their stuff
and I was always the one
who looked in the peek hole
and hear and see what's going on.
I see, I've been raped.
I saw my sister get raped.
Mom's an alcoholic, she's dead now
from cirrhosis of the liver.
Anyway, she would leave us
in the house by ourself.
We're little, you know what I'm saying?
And her boyfriend, I saw him
rape my sister and stuff.
It's so much, it's so much.
- [Interviewer] This
happened to you, as well?
- Yes.
My cousin did it to me, as well.
My uncle.
- [Interviewer] How old were you?
- Huh?
- I was like seven, eight.
Seven or eight years old.
My sister is two years older than me.
Oh, God, oh, my God, I'm sorry.
The memories of my past just fucks me up
as to the future of me now.
I'm 51 years old.
I have three children
and three grandchildren.
And all, man, okay.
Sorry.
I remember it always been cold.
I remember as a child, okay.
We had the pantry, the
cellar, the basement.
You know about Chicago, how
they got their shit, right?
Okay, we all playing or whatever
they down in the basement doing
their own shit, whatever.
And I was playing with some scissors
and I accidentally cut my hand.
I used to keep my hair,
my hair used to be really long,
jet black and curly.
I lived there, all kind of shit
and fucked my hair up as of now.
But anyway, my mom used to always keep
my hair in a ponytail.
I accidentally cut my hand
and I telling her, "Ma, I cut myself."
She wrapped my hand,
my ponytail around her hand
and she swung me around so that my feet
was in the air like this
and she's swinging me
and she unloosened me
and let me go and I hit my head,
face up against the fireplace
up in there and shit.
You know, we had the
radiators and shit out there.
You know what it's like out there, right?
So, it's like damn, who can I run to.
I don't know who to trust, what the fuck.
I can't go to my mom.
My granny have 14 children.
My mama was the oldest
and she only went to the third grade,
so she had to take care of all her sisters
and brothers, plus all of us, you know,
and she was an alcoholic.
Like I said, she died of
cirrhosis of the liver.
Anyway, oh, God, my head is
just bouncing around so much
'cause I don't have nobody to talk to,
won't nobody listen to me.
- [Interviewer] So you
left home at what age?
- Okay, 14, listen, okay, okay,
so after all that beatin' and shit
that my daddy did to my mom,
first my granny left and came
out here from Chicago, okay,
and then, she left us out there.
Like I said, I wish my mama
woulda left me with my daddy.
Anyway, my mom snuck us away from my dad
from all the abuse and the
beatin' and shit or whatever.
We caught the train out here
and she couldn't find, I think,
I don't know, maybe,
seven or eight, maybe nine,
I don't remember how old.
We came out here from Chicago.
We got on a train, okay,
you know how everybody
sleeping on a train or whatever.
My mom went in the bar or
whatever, she couldn't find,
she was like Trinity (indistinct),
she's screaming our name and shit.
Till they put us off the fuckin' train
and she said, they put her
in a drunk tank or whatever
and put us in the foster
home for one night
and put us back on the next train.
She said don't you tell
your grandma nothing.
When we came out here, we stayed
in the back of Lock High
School, I forget the name
of the street that we stayed.
I know you know about Lock
High School or whatever.
Damn, I have so much shit
going through my mind,
I forgot the fuckin' question.
What the fuck you say?
- [Interviewer] You left home.
- Oh, from the family, family.
Okay, I was like 14 years old, okay,
and we staying over there
in the hood or whatever.
Okay, first of all, I was a tomboy.
'Cause I seen all that shit happening
to my sister, getting raped and shit.
I didn't wanna fuckin' fuck,
what, nigga, what, uh-huh.
So I would do pop wheelies and anyway,
okay, fast forward.
I experienced with this guy,
I'm in my granny's house,
in a little room or
whatever with this guy.
He and I doing our thing or whatever.
I didn't know what to feel, anyway,
she knocked on my door,
she was like, "Jobena,
is that little short due
in there with you?"
I'm like, "No, ma'am."
She said, "Open the door."
I opened the door, he was hiding behind
the door with a coat behind him.
She was like, "If you old enough to fuck,
you old enough to get
the fuck outta my house."
So that's what I did.
I was like 14 and I've
been out since then.
Know what I mean?
Learning from the streets
and what I've learned from
what I saw in Chicago.
If all I know to do is this,
that's all I'm gonna do
until somebody teach me how to do this,
you know what I mean?
And that's what made me forget my mom
before she died because
that's all she was taught,
like I said.
She was fuckin' went to the third grade
'cause my granny had 14 children.
My granny was always a gambler
trying to get rich quick shit.
You know, she left her, my mom
to take care of her fuckin' responsibility
and she don't know what the fuck to do.
And just like me now
with my three children.
I don't, all I know is what I knew.
Shit.
I'm like, y'all need to break the cycle.
I don't want y'all to be like me,
be better than me.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't want them in a poor skid row.
I want them to have something in life.
I never beat my child.
I said when I have children
I will never, ever do to them,
my mom used to beat me with anything she,
a stool, she hit me in my leg
with a fuckin' hammer, you could see
the hole still in my leg.
She hit me in the leg with a hammer,
the part you pull the nail out with.
She would hit us with the pool stick,
the part you hold in your hand.
The extension cord, the douche bag,
you know the real douche bag,
you know what I'm with the enema stem
and all that shit.
She, man, my mama was no joke, man.
She done cut everybody in
the family, except for me.
The reason why she didn't cut me
is because she couldn't catch me.
I feel like this.
You're supposed to honor
your mother and father,
I don't give a fuck if my
mama was right or wrong,
she was right, always right,
even though I knew she was wrong.
I would never put my hands on my mama.
I would run from her and
there was this one time,
I told her, I said, "You know what?
"I think we need to take a blood test
because there is no way in the world
you supposed to treat a
child the way you treat me.
You treat my fuck off friends, children,
better than you treat me."
I said, "If you were my mama,"
I said, "Bitch if you weren't
my mom, I would fuck you up."
I said, "Ooh, mommy, I'm sorry."
Right away, right, you know
sucked the words back in
because I understand you're not supposed
to do that to your parents or whatever.
My mama was there, but her body,
sort of kind of not really,
but she was not there,
you know what I mean?
And before she died, we had a chance
to talk about stuff,
'cause we used to get high
together, you know what I mean?
She said, "Don't tell nobody,
don't tell nobody I'm
your mama, you my sister."
I didn't get that love.
I didn't get that hug.
I love you, rocking and all that shit.
She'd just say, "Bitch,
you better do what I said."
Like I said, I said I would never, never
do that to mine, never.
And at first I thought
I couldn't have children
because when I was nine years old,
my appendix ruptured and I almost died
and I was in the hospital
for like three months.
I had to learn how to walk
all over again, you dig?
And, 'cause my mama used to say
she thought I was being fast.
No, you know I was out there gang banging,
you know what I'm saying, doing shit,
making it happen.
Because when you have no, nothing,
I had to eat dog food and shit like that.
I don't even like dogs, but we had dogs.
I'm scared of dogs.
I got bit by a pit bull,
damn near locked on my leg.
Anyway, I'm back and bouncing around
because of what's going on in my mind,
like I said, I don't
have nobody to talk to,
won't nobody listen to me.
Anyway (crying).
Oh, God, we had a chance
to talk with each other.
I forgave her for some things,
she forgave me for some things
that I've said and done.
There was so more shit that
I wanted to tell my mom,
but I couldn't.
Like I said, she died of
cirrhosis of the liver
because I didn't want
her to die right there.
I love my mom, I miss my mama.
I don't care right it,
it said, look, R-I-P,
mama, my mama gone.
I don't have nothing or nobody
and my granny gone, too.
I love my granny.
I miss all of them.
My Uncle Chuck, I miss him so much.
He used to sing to me,
sing spiritual stuff.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm
sorry, I'm sorry, okay.
Let's just go back to what
you were talking about
'cause I'm going, bouncing around
and it's not cool, it's not.
I don't know what to do.
- [Interviewer] So you were
supporting yourself at 14?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] How were
you supporting yourself?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] How were
you supporting yourself?
- You really wanna know?
- [Interviewer] Yes.
- Breaking in houses,
stealing cars, jacking people.
I'm not proud of none of that shit.
I'm not.
I had to do what I had to do to survive.
I sure wouldn't get out there, shit,
sucking a fuckin' what?
Like right now.
Motherfucker, you wanna get high?
I'm like hey, okay, let's
get this shit straight
in the beginning so there won't be
no bullshit in the end.
I'm not doing no suckin',
fuckin', lickin',
touchin', I'm not blowin' or smokin'
and I don't wanna smoke
or be blown, like a fool.
What we can do is go
get one of these cars,
take it to the chop shop
or go up in one of these damn buildings,
get some shit and split that shit.
- [Interviewer] So prostitution
was never your thing?
- Hell, fuckin' no.
I told you my mama and then, my daddy
had them hos and shit, fuck that shit.
Hell to the fuckin' no, I
know how to fuckin' talk.
Get mine, get mine.
Fuck that.
What the hell, you better back up.
You see how I'm dressed, what?
And they still be tryna get at me.
I tried to (mumbling) so
they won't fuck with me,
but they still, Twig, can I get your...
Nigga, what, for what?
I don't know my number 'cause I don't have
to call myself, what the fuck.
Won't you just leave me alone.
I don't wanna be bothered.
I been through, if motherfuckers knew
the type of shit that
goes through my mind,
they wouldn't wanna be around me.
I don't even wanna be around me sometimes,
but everywhere I go there the fuck I am.
Nigga, what?
I got you, you, how I was raised,
but I got three fingers and a thumb
back at my dumb ass.
When am I gonna step up and show up?
Except what the fuck I did.
It's not all them.
I did some shit and I
said some shit, as well.
I'm not perfect and I
know damn well they not.
But I do know that I love
all of my motherfuckin' children
and there's nothing in this world
I would not do for them, you dig?
And with the situation me
going through right now,
motherfucker gonna tell me, this nigga,
my ex-husband tryna tell me
he only, he know that the only way
he can hurt me is through my children.
He's tryna turn them against me,
you dig what I'm sayin'?
He gonna tell me through text,
tell him I said, my son
said I called him an idiot.
You gots to be out your raggedy ass mind.
Ain't no fuckin' way I would tell my son
no shit like that, for real, really?
I love all of them.
There is nothing, I would stand
in front of a bullet for all of them.
I don't love no one no more or no less.
That's some bullshit.
This is what's going on with me right now.
I'm fuckin' stressed out.
I have high blood pressure,
I have scoliosis, I have pancreatitis,
you dig what I'm saying?
They cut me from here to here.
I died last year.
They had a toe tag on
my motherfuckin' ass.
And I still have diarrhea,
I been having diarrhea for over a year.
That's not cool.
That shit hurt and burn.
I could show you.
I don't give a fuck who see it.
I will show you, cut from here to here.
I had many surgeries, appendix,
like I said, when I told you my mom,
I thought my mama had, 'cause she thought
I was fast, but I wasn't being fast.
I was out there bangin' and shit.
What's up, cuz, you know that I'm saying?
But that shit, and I
found out it's stupid.
Well, how would you kill
your motherfuckin' brother
become a rat,
you don't own no motherfuckin' my turf,
what the fuck?
If you your mother...
Listen, I think I bought this, right?
I own this.
I still pay for this every time...
It get dirty I gotta wash it.
I gotta pay to get it washed,
so I don't own shit.
You got a motherfuckin' house,
you gotta pay mortgage, all this.
You got a car, you gotta put gas,
fluid, all that shit,
so you really don't own shit
so what the fuck, you gonna sit out there
and bang for?
That's stupid ass shit.
I did that shit.
But fuck that shit, mm-mm.
Here I'm talking about you still...
I don't blow the shit.
Da fuck, you can't make me do nothing
I don't wanna do.
You got me fucked up nigga
and I got you figured out.
Bitch, you're too much, what?
Pick a spot, boil 'em up.
This is just my flesh.
I know where I'm going.
I know whose I am.
Do you know whose you are?
Do you, hmm, I know who I am.
I know who I belong to, that's God.
You can take this old funky ass flesh.
But you can't take my spirit.
You can't.
Next question, what's happening?
- [Interviewer] So you
ended up on skid row.
You were homeless?
- I been down here off and on
since early 80s.
- [Interviewer] You've been homeless?
- Yes.
Didn't you hear what I said?
I was laying on the goddamn concrete,
oh, this is before you
turned on the camera.
This was before the camera came on.
Listen, so-called homeboys,
so-called homeboys
out here, you dig,
I'm laying on the goddamn concrete
with you fuckin' cardboard and shit.
(indistinct) I seen a
motherfucker stepping over me,
not Twin, come on, get
up, come on in my tent.
I can't do the tent shit.
I be smokin' like a mother fucker.
I been done burnt your mother fuckin',
I'll be puttin' holes in the shit
so I can see what the fuck is goings on.
I don't trust nothing, no one.
Nothing, no one, fuck that tent shit.
Yes, but I had one,
but the only time I went
in that mother fucker
to go, I didn't really
go to sleep, I passed out
for being up for days type shit.
Try to wash shit, the rats and all
that old punk ass shit.
You know what I mean?
I can't stand it.
I don't feel safe nowhere,
nowhere, no fuckin' where.
I been through too much, I seen too much.
Just like nigga, you don't even know
you in danger.
You don't know?
You gonna find out, keep fuckin' with me.
What how it happen captain.
You think you captain? Okay.
I just look like this and act like that.
I do have a good heart.
I will help mother fuckers.
I wanna help everybody.
What about me, though.
If I ain't no good to me,
how the fuck I'm a be so good to you?
So I don't give a fuck.
I do, but I don't.
'Cause mother fuckers don't know how
to appreciate that shit no way.
Wanna take advantage of a motherfucker
because I'm a female, look how bony I am,
but I will lift a, I
will body slam your ass
and fuck you the fuck off
and I'll feel bad afterwards
after I see blood come from you
'cause I used to bleed every month.
I don't have periods no more, I'm 51.
And I can still do the splits.
Listen, let me tell you something.
Dance is my passion.
I modern dance, ballet, tap dance,
sing, act and I play the drums by ear.
But really dance is my passion.
I wanna do this dance.
This is what I want you to do.
If I can come back up here,
I want you to film me doing that dance.
It's by Kirk Franklin, it's called
"Something About the Name of Jesus."
But I wanted to be at the
Exposition Rose Garden
and I can't nobody to
get from Ninth Street
to Tenth Street.
They in a fuckin' square.
Listen, come on, let's go do
some other shit, niggas.
Just fuck.
Da fuck.
Open up your mind and your heart,
let's go somewhere.
- [Interviewer] What was
the best time of your life?
- Dancing.
I used to dance on stage,
it was called Benya Recreation Center
on Farmdale and Vineyard.
We used to put on shows and shit.
Plays and I won trophies.
- [Interviewer] When you were a kid?
- Mm-hmm.
I miss that shit.
I love it.
I want, like I said, I want someone
to film me doing that dance.
I have a spiritual, I have
the outfit part of it.
I just need some white gloves.
Anyway, I was supposed to dance,
'cause I dance.
And I wanna do that before
I go to sleep sleep.
Y'all can put it on YouTube, blue tube,
whatever the fuck ever.
But I wanna do that dance,
'cause I can still do the splits.
- [Interviewer] You sure can.
- And I'm gonna do it.
But won't nobody take time to do it.
- [Interviewer] What was
the worst time of your life?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] What was
the worst time of your life?
- Every day.
Every mother fuckin' day.
But the worst, worst, worst,
worst time of my life,
damn, it's been so many times.
Wow, that's a helluva
question right there.
The worst time, imagine that.
It's been so much bad shit happening,
I can't pinpoint that, boy.
You dig what I'm saying?
The worst time, shit.
Are you for real?
The worst time in a fuckin'
dysfunctional family,
from the mother fuckin' granny
down to the great, great granny
and the great, great, great, great granny,
cousins, uncles and all that shit.
OMG, are you serious?
I know you didn't ask me that question.
- [Interviewer] How many kids of you have?
- I have three children,
a kid is a baby goat.
I have three children
and three grandchildren.
- [Interviewer] Did you raise your kids?
- Well, sort of kind of not really.
Okay, what happened was,
like I said, my sister was older than me,
then my brother.
They had some (mumbling) after us, anyway.
My sister couldn't have children.
She was always jealous of me,
like I said, we don't have the same daddy,
got the same mom and daddy spoiled me
and didn't really pay no attention.
My sister was older,
to her and I didn't like that,
you know what I'm saying?
I figure you should
treat 'em all the same.
And so I loved my sister.
I still love her.
She's two years old than me
and I always wanted that
sister, sister relationship
and a mother daughter relationship,
but I never had that shit.
You know what I'm saying?
Aw, shit.
Mm, mm, mm, I hate this.
Man, you be making me dig,
you making me dig
and I just...
I just...
Sometimes I just shut
down because like I said
I was always told shut the fuck up,
get outta here, no kids in here.
And then some people will use
what I say against me or try to, you know,
as a tool or whatever and then I'm,
I try to say something they'd try
to talk while I'm talking
and it's like, damn, I'm
not talking 'bout you,
I'm talking to you about shit
that's happening in my
life, what the fuck?
Why you wanna defend something
that don't need to be defended?
Put on a shoe that don't even fit?
I don't need you to comment,
just fuckin' give me your ear.
Right now, that I have you
to give you my ear,
I'm on motherfuckin' cameras and shit,
it's like fuck, you know what I mean?
But I don't care, fuck it.
Say, what?
You know what I mean? For real.
- [Interviewer] What emotion
comes up for you the most?
Is it anger, is it depression, anxiety?
- All that.
Bipolar, schizophrenic, paranoid.
I think somebody gonna get me.
Gonna kill me 'cause I seen
all that shit going down
in my life.
I seen people get shot, stabbed.
I'm talking about as a child
all the way up to now.
Even down here.
When I was first introduced downtown,
I was like what the fuck,
this is a whole new fuckin' life.
I never seen this shit.
Shit.
They had tents, a whole bunch of tents.
This is way back when the police
used to throw dope at
the window at people.
I'm like what the fuck?
And it was tents and umbrellas and lights
and all you saw was a gang of damn light.
My brother introduced me to downtown.
I don't wanna say his name.
But, yeah, he introduced me to downtown.
It's like wow.
I seen a motherfucker
get killed up a pusher,
over a wire hanger.
That's some bullshit.
You gonna kill a motherfucker
for a pusher, to push a pipe?
I seen all kind of shit.
I remember when I was
getting high one time
behind this dumpster down here
and there was some boxes back there
and I heard some shit.
I didn't hit the shit yet, right?
And I kicked the box and a rat stood up.
I said, oh, shit, I jumped up right.
It's not funny, it's funny now,
but it wasn't funny then.
So, I started running.
I swear to God the rat chased me.
When I jumped over the box,
that motherfucker, that motherfucker,
when he stand up, he was about that tall.
Worse than the ones in Chicago, anyway,
I bent the corner, the
rat bent the corner.
I said what the f....
And they named the rat,
I forgot the name of the rat.
This was like years ago, but anyway, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have friends in your life?
- Hmm?
- [Interviewer] Do you
have friends, good friends?
- Friends? Da fuck? Friends?
I have associates. Friends?
God is my friend.
Kidding me.
They say I have trust
issues, abandonment issues.
You know what I'm saying, it's like
what the hell, pshh.
Friends? Wow, what's that?
What's that? What's a friend?
- [Interviewer] Do you feel like you use
what happened to you as a child
as an excuse for the
situation you're in today?
- Hell, no.
Mm-mm, like I said, when I point at you,
I got three fingers
and a thumb back at me.
Mm-mm.
I used to.
So that would give me,
so I could keep on doing, but as I grew,
and opened up my mind,
pay attention to my
surroundings and everything,
I learned that, huh,
they did what the fuck,
the best they could.
Not they fault.
Like I said, all you know to do this,
that's what you gonna do until you open
up your mind, stop being stubborn
to learn how to do this.
You know what I mean? Shit.
So I used to blame them and say that shit
but then I thought, you know,
like with my children.
I did the best the fuck I could.
I did what I was taught.
It's a cycle.
You learn from your surroundings
what you watch on TV and
people around you, you dig?
So, if I, if I, if I
try to break that cycle
and stop doing what I saw as a child,
not let my children see that shit,
then maybe it'll make it different.
I don't know.
- [Interviewer] Where are your kids today?
What are they doing?
- I don't know.
One is 23 with three children.
One is 24 and she's fixing
to have her first baby
and then my son is 15.
I believe he's somewhere in Long Beach.
- [Interviewer] But they have jobs,
they're staying out of trouble?
- Yeah, they do pretty good, yeah.
I'm proud of them.
- [Interviewer] Do you talk to them?
- Well, I haven't spoken to them,
but like I said, my ex-husband,
which is my second daughter's father
is trying to turn them against me.
So we used to talk and shit.
Now, no answers, no text,
no calls, no nothing.
They said I call my son an idiot.
Ain't no fuckin' way I'm gonna call
my son a fuckin' idiot, what?
I think he did, he said it was a text.
Did it come out his mouth? Uh-huh.
'Cause he not doing well, oh, whatever.
He wants to see his mama.
Well then come, let him see me.
What the fuck?
It might help him, motivate him
to do better in school,
you dig what I'm sayin'?
I'm not saying that, you know,
it's real bad, just better.
He wants his fuckin' mama
and I want all my children.
I wanna be in my grandchildren's life
but they wanna shut me out
because of what they said.
Did you see it?
Have I ever did anything to hurt you
or treat you wrong?
I've never did what my mama did to me
to my children, never, ever.
Never.
I said when I have my children
I ain't gonna do them like she did me.
She would beat us until
the blood come out.
That's child abuse.
She would have a extension cord
and braid it up and get another one
and braid it up and tie it up in a knot
so you can't grab it from her and just...
- [Interviewer] You feel
like life is unfair?
- (clearing throat) No, it ain't life.
I used to.
It's not life.
I found out when I do what I always do,
I get what I always got.
Everything begins and ends with me.
Life is not a bitch, it's
truly what I make of it.
I've got choices.
I didn't know I had choices then.
Like I said, I'm 51,
I've learned that, hmm...
If I go this way, this
is what gonna happen.
If I go this way, that's
what's gonna happen.
If I go this way, it's gonna
be something different.
I have choices.
- [Interviewer] You take responsibility?
- Hmm?
- [Interviewer] You take
responsibility for...
- For my fuckin' actions, hell, yeah.
And I ain't got a problem
with saying I apologize.
I ain't fuckin' near, I'm far from sorry,
I apologize, I was wrong.
How can I make it right?
If you don't, fuck it then?
Keep that shit up on your,
you gonna feel if I feel fuckin blessings
in front of you, tripping
'bout the fuckin' past.
All them logs in front of you,
you gonna fall on your fuckin' mug.
You gonna fall on your face.
Let that shit go.
Can't go shit about it no way.
What I'm get a whoopin'.
I do what the fuck I wanna do
when I wanna do it.
I have choices.
I know there's consequences.
Action causes reaction.
And sometimes I be like fuck it,
I don't give a fuck.
But I do care.
But I get into that part where,
'cause they shutting me
out, meaning my children,
she was like fuck it then,
I don't care, fuck it.
Fuck it then, come on with it.
And I take it out on somebody else,
that's called displaced anger.
Take my shit off on someone else
because I can't control what the fuck
is going on my my mother fucking circle.
I'm powerless, I don't have
no fuckin' control, what?
I wanna do something bad.
I act out.
I know better.
I just look like this once again
and act like that.
It's better to not know
then to know because I know,
I'm talking spiritual now.
I'm getting whopped.
I can't enjoy shit.
A beer, a joint, nothing.
Can't get high, how?
'Cause I know better.
It took me a while to learn that
considering what I've learned growing up
as a child with this sick,
because that's how they grew up.
That's what they learned,
so they instilled it on me
and they thought the same thought,
I was gonna put it on my
children when I didn't.
I kept that shit away from them.
They didn't know.
They probably heard about it,
but they never seen me do nothing.
Made sure of that.
- [Interviewer] Do you believe in God?
- Yes, I do.
Yes, I do.
He has never failed me and never will,
never have and always on time.
I will die for him.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
- Take responsibility, own up to my stuff,
you know, be patient with myself.
The hardest part I'm having with
is being able to forgive myself
for the shit that I allowed to happen
in my own life.
Most important lesson is to just love me
and I'm still working
on trying to forgive me
so I can grow and be
a better mom, grandma.
I want my children in my life.
That's what I'm going through with them.
Going through man, this is fuckin' stupid.
I hate this shit, you don't know, man,
I want my babies, I want my babies,
I want my babies, I'm sorry,
I just want my babies (crying).
They keep lyin' on me.
All you gotta do is ask me,
I'm a tell you, I will tell you.
You don't have to lie on me, but.
But....(crying).
Oh, shit, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Oh, God.
But I know he gonna fix it.
I know he gonna fix it in time.
Hopefully before I die,
I wanna see my babies and my grandbabies
and my daughter fixin'
to have her first baby.
I wanna be here to watch it.
And they setting me up
because of what a motherfucker said.
I hate this shit.
And I keep beating myself up.
Oh, God, okay.
Okay, my chest is hurting now.
Okay, breathe, breathe girl.
Oh, God, breathe.
It's hot in here, fuck.
Man, I say, man this is
some stupid shit (crying).
Oh, God.
Oh, I'm telling you my chest is hurtin'.
You got some water,
ice water or something?
You don't understand, this is
not no fuckin' made up story,
this is real shit.
Real live bull... man, God,
I can't do nothing about it.
God, I'm tryin', I'm tryin', I am.
I wanna go back to school
and get my high school diploma
or either GED and study
Spanish and computers,
and you know why?
'Cause they motherfuckin'
told me I couldn't.
I'm 51, I wanna do it for me,
not because I wanna get
a degree or nothing.
I just wanna prove to myself
that I can do it because
that bitch told me I couldn't.
You ain't shit, you ain't gonna
never be shit, bitch, what?
Uh!
God help me get this and what.
Shit.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Calm down, Jobena, calm down.
I need a cigarette.
All that shit that I know
that's fuckin' my body up,
I be asking for, cigarette.
Come on now.
Drink, come on now.
I got pancreatitis, come on now.
Fuck.
- [Interviewer] Do you still smoke?
- Hell, yeah, I smoke cigarettes.
- [Interviewer] No, I mean crack.
- No.
No (sobbing).
I smoke weed and I drink
like a motherfucker
and I smoke like six
packs of cigarettes a day
because I got beer right here.
I might be full of shit.
I ain't lyin', see.
- [Interviewer] Oh, so
alcohol is your deal?
- I drink hard liquor, too,
where my other bottle at?
It's down there somewhere.
But here, and I can't get drunk.
I can't get high.
Too much shit on my mind and my heart
and because I know that
God don't want me to do it.
This shit ain't working, but fuck it.
I try to drown it out,
the feelings that I be feelin'.
Like I said for the shit
that I allow to happen
in my life.
Anyway, I never did finish
telling you about my sister.
She couldn't have children, right?
So I had let her use my husband,
well, he's not my husband
no more, you know, make
and I'm standing behind
him, make that like,
so she can't the pills you supposed to get
so she can get pregnant.
I even told her I will put,
let them put your shit inside of me
and have the baby for you.
This bitch set me up and
took my girls from me.
She beat them, did all kinda shit to them
and I couldn't do nothing about it.
And I think they angry at me about that.
'Cause my daughter, she was two years,
she was like, I'm, don't worry,
my mama gonna come get me.
She going to the program,
she gonna come get me.
My daughter, my oldest daughter,
she was always sassy.
Still is.
She's 24, fixin' to have her first baby.
Like I said, I was 24 when
my first baby, which is her.
I don't wanna say none of their names
'cause I know this is,
but when they see this shit,
they gonna know what the
fuck I'm talkin' about.
Know what I mean?
Yep, they gonna know.
I want you guys to know
that I love all of y'all.
I don't even know, I know,
okay, I have three grandchildren.
I don't know the third one's name.
I have two girls and a boy, children
and two girls and a boy, grandchildren
and one grandchild on the way
and I believe it's a girl
and I wanna be there.
I do.
But I have to get me together.
They keep on whispering that shit
they motherfucking
heard about me, goddamn.
They never even took the time out
to really get to know me.
You going by what the fuck
he said, she said, shit.
My sister said, I was
fixin' to say her damn name.
Ooh, but yeah.
Get to know me.
Fuck what you heard.
You don't know me.
You probably know of me.
You never seen me do shit but
drink and smoke cigarettes.
If y'all don't let that shit go,
that shit gonna pass on
to your damn children
and their children's children
if the rapture don't come before me.
I just wanna send a message to my babies,
let them know I love them,
am I still filming?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I love y'all, man, stop that shit,
fuck about what you heard.
Get to know me.
Know me.
I am your mother,
you came outta my pussy.
Don't listen to that fuckin' shit.
Don't listen to that shit.
I'm hurting.
Do you see I'm really fucking hurting?
That shit is a lie.
I never called my son a fuckin' idiot.
That's a fuckin' lie, I love y'all.
I want y'all to be better than me.
Don't be like what my mama did to me
about this, that the other.
Be better than me.
You guys are smart, you strong.
Be the best mama you can be.
Both of y'all, you know
who I'm talkin' to.
And my son, I want you to be the king
that I know you are.
Pick it up, bring it up,
do what you do.
You got a car at 15.
I ain't have no damn car at 15
and if I did I stole it.
I broke in that motherfuckin' car
and I stole it.
You earned that car, yeah.
Do you, be better than me.
You don't wanna be downtown on skid row.
This is no joke.
I done showed you girls already
what it's like.
I brought y'all down here
when I had my blue Dodge Caravan
and I showed you, this is what you want?
This is what your life could be like
if you do not focus or do
what you supposed do to in school.
Fuck what you heard.
I love you.
Peace.
- [Interviewer] Thank you, Jobena.
- [Jobena] I need a hug, I need a hug.
- [Woman] Nope.
- [Jobena] Nobody loves me.
Nobody helps, I need help,
but I don't have nobody to talk to.
It's just me and my fuckin' cat.
(Jobena crying)
Oh, Lord have mercy,
Jesus Christ, imagine it.
Oh, wow.
Hey.
- Yeah.
- [Jobena] Excuse me.
You are a good listener, thank you.
- [Interviewer] Oh, darlin', thank you.
- [Jobena] I have more shit.
- [Woman] How about this?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.